skitty welcome to a new van last week I
asked you write me a poem that's right
Christian channel we do poetry every
Sunday now that's right now I can
already tell you guys have failed as
always I asked for poets what do I get
shitty memes shut up it's not funny
well it's my duty to review it that's
why I'm here to review your poems ok
I'll give you a poem right now so how is
it is roses are red violets are blue
alright let's go let's go let's review
them I've seen this one
ok wait oh I see you changed it it's not
a poem though say nipa and nobody bats a
nice okay alright moving on the
possibility of World War 3
PewDiePie says the n-word ones my name
uppity PI and I respect women Sweden is
my city
Marcia Edgar and Maia my life I don't
need to make new content my squad fem
just set for me when my girlfriend's out
fake Marcia's
my BAE scare PewDiePie may have got
cancelled but I still got paid anyway
you did it you did it you did the Poe
and I found your future hey I'll take it
that looks freaking hot man god damn
pity pie is blue markiplier is red
jacksepticeye is green and together they
are the Powerpuff Girls how is that a
poem get get out of this his content is
dying just as I feared not racist
stop lying but look at that beard I pray
every day his hair is white he makes me
gay I think about him at night he
respect women he'll always be licked he
can't afford salmon because YouTube
alright not bad not bad
oh here Oh cute
what's the night Perry adsence when all
through the tube not a person was
dreaming not even our pewds the salary
would come by the morning we thought in
hopes that st. Google's and Revenue will
have brought when out on the forums
arose such a cheetah I sprang from my
bed to check on my Twitter away from the
videos it flew like a flash tore open
the website and threw out the ads pute
sprang to our aid to his team gave a
whistle and back him the ads like the
down of a thistle the antenna collapse
was over what a hero that our fellow
happy youtubing wait why are all my
videos yellow told wait why my old
videos yellow actually they're not
anymore Christian Channel it works every
time Christian Channel Beauty back who
would have thought family friendly get
up yeah
Christian Channel that's what I'm
talking about it changes everything
hahaha Oh Cesare red violets are blue
the only thing I want to say is lesser
users you use the pen tool god damn it I
mean gosh darn it I mean gosh darn it
you know what these are not bad so far
good job also I realized I look a little
short let it go now I look taller here's
a poem about PewDiePie a man who touched
the sky all the hitters will say why cuz
he's Christian Channel now here's a wall
new twist something you may have missed
I bet you to know Jesus Christ is a bro
oh [ __ ] too bad I'm not doing a brofist
in that picture but whatever you know I
digress oh my god this is like some
ancient scroll [ __ ] man that once was
asleep that went on to lead a squad of a
fam England their City despite all the
worst they kept to the cause and day
after day 0 death Erica respect women
for laugh sister faith chill with dad
and dap on the better okay
violets are blue roses are red I hope
slippies not sleep is not dead stop
saying my tote is dead it looks bad for
there's a difference between dead and
sleeping alright I woke him up from his
fellow slumber roses are red violets are
blue you make you too better by just
being you oh no something nice there
must be a twist oh my god thank you
that's so sweet
a poem for Ione what the heck the past
now is fleeting with all our early
struggles I came here for nostalgia all
I got was puzzle yes good that was
awesome dude so if you don't know if
you're a fake Fanny you didn't watch the
only video I'm just kidding yeah I came
for an Italian the game was just puzzles
and he ruined all the nostalgia man Oh
day by day made one okay all right what
do we get P is for powerful the top top
he okay's poor expectations starting to
drop W is for women we respect a lot D
is for D monetization which wasn't your
doing yes right it was to all that are
viewing e is for those eyes that are
clearly attractive P is for the portion
of your subs that are active
additionally causing some drama and II
know the end of this poem for Papa
sure sure sure you could have been a
little nicer okay that's cool so you
took my tutorial and you did my
thumbnail that's so cool
if you idiot you clearly haven't learned
anything my god what is his garbage i'd
have to trace enough to trace out your
garbage okay
disgusting I told you I told you about
contrast
goodnight told him about you what is
this garbage I can't even see what it is
also why did you add the stupid
microphone there huh what does that does
that add anything to the picture I think
not
yeah at least I know how to make a
goddamn thumbnail there you go
alright let's look at your garbage look
at mine perfect garbage perfect garbage
perfect go home you know what this might
actually be true maybe my dad was Hagrid
after all and that's why
JK Rowling hates me so much it all makes
sense can you guys tell JK I'm a
Christian Channel now so maybe she would
take me back I would really appreciate
that roses are red violets are blue
Peter Pie stole this idea from Jack's
films too he makes one every single day
every day how am I supposed to know can
you guys seriously it's not cool
Jack hasn't been replying to my texts
there's clearly something off between us
and you guys aren't helping by implying
that I'm stealing his content because
you can't steal content if there's none
there to begin with
[Music]
I feel confident that 2017 is gonna be a
much better year did I actually say that
well you know what can you do [ __ ] up
again you are snooze articles everywhere
now I'm hated quick better save the ad
revenue so christian pewdiepie activate
that's right um I've come back to
YouTube to save it with Christian
Channel
if you're not a Christian Channel I urge
you to join me on my quest to save the
ad revenue I'm the Messiah and the
destroyer get it
roses are red violets are blue Wall
Street Journal oh my why machine I think
this is my favorite that's awesome well
done
nutty LMFAO it's very nice to meet you
my name is Jeff I'm from Ohio and so is
Jake Paul multi-millionaire goddamn
can't even get an a/c installed oranges
are orange but apples are red I thought
I could cure him by getting rid of his
forehead
summer is for swimsuits fall is for
flannel have so many subscribers they're
trying to kill my channel it's almost
2018 don't make fun of my [ __ ] frog
PewDiePie is still the most sub Channel
and believe you used to sell hot dogs
roses are red violets are blue not
actually mad you wouldn't follow me on
Twitter but also Kristen Channel can't
show roses I read good Christians
rejoice Swedish man draws penis with his
voice yes we found the queen and king of
YouTube oh my god someone took a picture
of us that's so awkward I was feel like
I'm so watching these scenarios
and now you know what I guess I am it
was really good I really loved the
concert though just say hi you don't
know don't take sneak peeks man it's
weird
roses are red violets are bigger misses
shut and pub gee no no no it's a
question channel now ah dude alright you
know what
well done I am actually not completely
disappointed this time I'm just slightly
uh you know for once for once you sort
of took my challenge and you accepted it
and you know what this one is for you
because you know what you didn't do
terrible so at least you get a little
clap see good job what do you want huh
what do you that's it that's it go go
the video is over just go why haven't
you gone yet
leave a like while you're at it then huh
have you done that yeah what do you want
you we don't want the Pollard's to take
over is that what subscribe mix
challenge challenge for next week will
be alright what is text from student now
food related that's right
anything take PewDiePie take food and
smash them together alright anything
food related
you can submit that's it for me for now
love you guys so much
let me Gais so much squad family